nur wenige mauerreste gibt es noch in
berlin etwa die von künstlern bemalten
teile an der east side gallery an
schrecken der grenze erinnert die
gedenkstätte berliner mauer wieder aufs
markieren nur noch pflastersteine den
verlauf der innerstädtischen grenze
dabei interessiert gerade dieses kapitel
viele berlin zu recht
[Musik]
man müsste mehr davon sehen gerade
weiter für ein historischer die
mauerteile finde ich gut aber man hätte
jährige flüchtige bedeutung mehrwert
hätten
genau darum geht es in dem 2006
eröffneten mauer panorama ihr sohn
besucher das leben in der ehemals
geteilten stadt nachempfinden sie kaufen
einen das berlin der 1980 er jahren an
einem grauen novembertag werfen sie
einen blick von westberlin aus hinüber
in den osten
[Musik]
musik vermischt mit tonaufnahmen aus der
damaligen zeit soll das erlebnis
verstärken
[Musik]
ich habe noch viel gänsehaut so hat man
sich gar nicht vorstellen dass ich jetzt
gesehen habe ich mir kennt die bilder
gefertigt aber das hier ist dabei zwar
nicht kontaktieren
das war sehr beeindruckend den
geschichtlichen hintergründen man spürt
ihn doch im raum
eineinhalb jahre hat der perser ständige
künstler yadegar assisi an dem
panoramabild gearbeitet
durch den fünf meter von der berliner
mauer entfernt und kuchen über
gefährlicher bauer vom weg in richtung
ort und sehen dass menschen neben dieser
mauer leben böse überall leben also ohne
zu begreifen dass sie neben der bellen
nummer oder oder zu registrieren der
viele hinter der mauer yadegar asisi
bildet den alltag im schatten der mauer
ab atmosphärische dichte ist ihm
wichtiger als dokumentarische treue
sein blick ist der eines zeit sorgen
denn er hat wird jahrelange den teil von
berlin gelebt den er in seinem panorama
inszeniert
fast alles was wir hier sehen ja habe
ich erlebt und deswegen muss zwischen
schwächen meiner recherche war mein
vierjähriger assisi kam in wien zur welt
und wuchs in der ddr auf
1978 wurde er nach westberlin
abgeschoben und wohnten
für ihn war die betonmauer in teil
seines alltags am computer setzt er
seine welt von damals neuzugang
auszeichnungen und unzählige fotos die
er mit statisten aufgenommen hat
diese patina dieser zeit so zwar auch zu
kreieren
das ist gar nicht so einfach dann
wirklich accessoires aufzufinden aus der
zeit dass diese seite auf lebt und das
geht eben von der verfallenen verfahren
bis zum kaugummi automat der damaligen
zeit ja also man muss dann schon sehr
konsequent sein
für das 15 meter hohe und 60 meter
breite rundbild wurde eigens eine
rotunde mit einem besucher turm gebaut
20 stoffbahnen wurden bedruckt ein
zusammengepackt
der logistische und finanzielle aufwand
ist erheblich
die problematik beim panorama es ist
einfach alles riesig ist und sofort ins
geld geht man eigentlich nicht daran
glaubt dass so was für den einzelnen
könnte war machbar
mit dem panorama die mauer widmet er
sich erstmals einem thema der
zeitgeschichte das riesen rund betreiber
mal alltäglich und subtil grausam
zugleich die normalität geteilten stadt
waren leute wenn herausgehen werden
ich habe an der berliner mauer gestanden
es wird viel realer erinnerung zur
realität wird
vielleicht werden sie auch vielleicht
paket an wärme über die ich mich
eigentlich arrangieren wenn so was mit
mir passiert oder sie gehen für mich
doch auch in meinem leben in anderen
filmen privaten und so weiter ich glaube
dass recht viele fragen zu aber
vielleicht wartet bei denen sie das
geteilte berlin erlebt haben wirkt das
panorama erinnerung und touristen
vermittelt es einen eindruck vom leben
an der mauer